[Music]
so many things that I obviously love
about your work but one of the things
you do that you you have a real sense of
fun and mischief in the work that you
create and you're always putting little
hidden things in your movies and your
projects that give you joy well it's a
kind of like in joke thing with the
people with whom I work it's sort of
like like you know hiding you know r2d2
is hidden in this movie and there's this
like this beverage called slush show
that we created that's in all the movies
we do there's just all these stupid
little things that if you care to look
for it you'll find them it's kind of
like remember a you know Nina when the
first we hire get your artist her
daughter's name would be hidden which is
one of those things that if you knew to
look for it
you'd find yeah it's and and and slusho
that was it's a slushie drink that you
put into the show alias we had it in the
first episode and for some weird reason
we've been hiding it thank you we've
been hiding it ready those are the kind
of things that make you happy you put
them in like for example years ago when
I wrote for The Simpsons I put Jubjub
into a Simpsons episode oh yeah and so I
know that if I ask you because we're
very close and I think you're closer to
me than anyone in the world I know that
if I ask you you'll put Jubjub into a
Star Wars movie I know you'll get it in
somehow I know that you'll does that's
going to happen
does anyone else wants anything just
shouting what's gonna happens people
gonna see that you're gonna you're a
nice guy you're gonna say yes and then
this the Star Wars movies will make no
sense
we flip flop bluff liar you know it's
very early days that and and if and when
I am directing Star Wars Jubjub somehow
will find it that's fantastic
I'm the happy guy now and I can die not
just yet 80 years from now